tonight the bloody scene which greeted
police officers when they arrived at
Oscar pistorius's house and the Olympian
is again left an extreme physical
distress after graphic pictures of his
shot girlfriend are accidentally shown
during the hearing good evening from
North Houghton High Court in Pretoria
where a senior police officer has told
how he followed a trail of blood through
the home of Oscar Pistorius to the
bathroom where reeva Steenkamp was shot
Colonel Sean B van Rensburg described
how he arrived at the scene in the early
hours of Valentine's Day last year so
graphic where the photos seen by the
court that unemotional Pistorius broke
down and vomited he denies the
premeditated murder of his 29 year old
girlfriend a warning that Paul
Harrison's report contains pictures that
some viewers may find distressing
such is the interest in the trial of
Oscar Pistorius there's often as much
focus placed on the accused and his
demeanor as there is on the evidence
itself what is it that you see I see
there the first deviously example mr.
Pistorius wearing socks blood on the
legs bloody images such as this one of
the prosthesis worn by the olympian on
the night of the shooting are by now
commonplace your second proposition was
of course it could have happened that
mark could have been imprinted on that
panel by the prosthetic foot in him
stumbling on it and causing them all
that's great but of course we have now
four to 120 that we can look at again so
when you stumble on the plank it would
be on the reverse side to the backside
this one was on the front side so it's
facing the floor in this photograph but
unwittingly the court was today twice
shown graphic images of reeva Steenkamp
body
Oscar Pistorius his reaction can first
be heard he then visibly Wretch's as he
hides from the grim images shown to the
court he's then passed a bucket
a change of witness one of the first
policeman to the scene of the shooting
but with him no let-up in the nature and
significantly the volume of the grisly
pictures and testimonies but in part due
to Oscar pistorius's earlier reaction to
the macabre
images photographs of his dead
girlfriend reeva Steenkamp would not be
shown in court the next witness will
deal with the scene of crime we have
taken out of the presentation that will
be screened all images depicting the the
body of the deceased the roots of birth
by the Elohim there was a body laying
down giving evidence largely through a
translator
Colonels Huma van Rensburg described the
injuries reeva Steenkamp appeared to
have suffered there was a head wound
there was a wound on the right hand side
of the waist there was a wound on the
right and also on the left arm on the
left hand the witness said he'd been
told by the daughter of the estate
manager where Pistorius lived that the
Olympian had wanted to use his car to
take reeva Steenkamp to hospital but had
been advised to wait for an ambulance
she also asked mr. Pistorius as she told
me to get something else also to stop
the bleeding she and mr. Pistorius
together they tried to stop the bleeding
she also further explained to me that
when they arrived on the scene mr.
Pistorius said to them that he thought
that the deceased was an intruder by
this stage Oscar Pistorius had already
carried his girlfriend from the bathroom
where he claims he shot her unwittingly
through his bedroom and down the stairs
to the ground floor and so with the help
of a series of crime-scene photographs
Colonel van Rensburg helped the court
understand the route he took tracing the
trail of blood back up to the bathroom
we then followed the trail of blood
at this stage let us just deal with that
the elbow you have in front of you
that's exhibit if open it up at the
first photograph that's photograph
number two enter through the main door
and you look to your right you'll see
the character this that is the wooden
door that you see there on the left-hand
side of the wooden door it's a small
sitting room so one could see it on
photograph three just left of the door
does it just close a close-up of that
area that varies correct my lady and
unwearied all six one of the chairs in
that specific area
am i correct that is correct my lady
they need anything significant than that
fur grows on the photograph two spots
there and that would be of blood on the
chair on the chin of the stool on the
chain this is another chain that
specific area and on photograph seven
yes that is correct this as chair was on
the left-hand side of the other chair
that was shown previously the way
several blood spots as you can see also
they on the channels and on the chair as
well as spots one consider that square
daddy daddy spirit and the Delta forever
of tenders were blood spots on the top
row that is correct
Meli paragraph eleven that option
ninety-four fluid that is the bottom
part of the stairs the body of the
deceased lay on the left-hand side of
those stairs as on the photograph and
and that repeat more clear on paragraph
12 that is the pillar and
just below that pill and this is where
the deceased was laying this is the
beginning of the stairs the first set of
stairs going up and the spot one can see
there on the photograph that is the the
often the deep blue sport but most of
all this is part of the blood trail that
we were following that's all on the
stairs going up the closeup of the blood
this correctly very lady the same with
Farouk fighter 60 you can see the
railing they on the right hand corner
that was perfect where the circuit is
now yeah fan Rensburg who arrived at the
scene less than an hour after the
shooting then described seeing blood
spattered on the walls of the staircase
leading up to the first floor you're
coming down it will be on the right hand
side but if you're standing going up
with the stairs this isn't all and left
hand side and what is that yet let us
booklet you still funny blood splatters
this is also blood part of the blood
trail that we are following but this is
the same wall it is painted here but you
can also see
it is also next to the stairs although
photographs can still remember yes I can
remember my lady in one photograph you
can see the Shelf of trophies won by the
athlete over many years this is when you
get to the best floor this is where the
flow begins you will also notice just
towards that wooden door there are also
blood sports when you stand on top of
the stairs and you would look down as
you would have come up then at the exact
same spot and you look to your straight
ahead
that is the view you have in 3227 that
is correct and my lady in the photograph
I covered the in the right hand side in
the city where the circle is now this is
where the witness mrs. stander showed to
us the place where she took the towers
from when looking for the linen cabinet
or the qaol cabinet further on and one
can see a door that a door that is the
door to the sleeping area that is not at
the spirit it's a door to a spare room
when you can see it on this photograph
the spots on the tower floor can you
identify that that is correct my lady
what are those the Bridgeport was there
blood trails that we were following if
we go to 33 what is that that is a small
sitting room right at the entrance of
the main bedroom if you want to enter
into the main bedroom you would have to
pass that carpet and then move towards
the right if you look to what you're
left the view would be what one can see
at photographs 34 that is correct my
lady this is the entrance into the main
bedroom and the spot one can see there
on
just the ofany principle it's part of
the bloodstream that was there the wall
on the back oh is that the unit which on
top of which there is a - that the a
indicates blood spatter on the floor
that is correct that's after the
entrance into the main bedroom that's
the door to the main bedroom and the
black object one can see there which is
a Windex a gun the door with damage to
it you know where that is that is a hole
through the door through the main bed
bedroom door my metronome paragraph 46
deal with damage to the main bedroom
door that you see that no I did not pick
that up 51 is a close-up of the cabinet
with the sunglasses in it and 52 one can
see the a gun and what what's next to it
the peril of Elvis in the blue object
next to the gun
you see the bed both Bob fifty bases
great baseball coming up the court has
shown the bloody scene at the bathroom
where reeva Steenkamp was shot dead and
the police colonel tells how pistorius's
gun was found on the floor ready to fire
welcome back to Pretoria and the
continuing trial of Oscar Pistorius for
the murder of his girlfriend the day's
evidence has been dominated by Colonel
Swami's van Rensburg testimony of the
scene which officers discovered at the
Pistorius house using a series of at
times graphic photographs the judge had
two Assessors and the rest of the court
were guided up the stairs and into the
bedroom since I arrived fond of that
cloud of fear it will be to nail the
Edler after I had arrived on the scene
with my lady and so I went up with with
the nobody else into that sea but the
fan they said oh this guy when you go to
the sea was that door open or closed
that door was open my lady
the Katan we're drawn open as the way
today they were not closed
what's the gray object on the floor in
front of the fan the second one is a
debate the people the first one the SDN
is a broker-dealer group and the first
one it's a denim trouser and remember
that pill yes that would be on the
right-hand side of the bed as you would
be standing in front of it does that
look familiar
that is the magazine and the holster and
with bullets this which we found on the
right hand side and company whoops
welcome that would be nearer to where
the fan was and there on the left-hand
side is a fan this rapid that is correct
my lady was not plugged in anyway the
square is correct my lady they were not
switched on it also goes for the other
fan it was in photo the other photo they
were cell phones there were cell phone
was there but I didn't concentrate on
that solvents Cyrano no I actually
didn't see it
the placas any longer company baited by
Mac artist on what I specifically
remember there it is the sandals I work
the issue a sit placed together and
there is also an overnight bag that is
also on
on the left there is a whole step
did you see that holster yes it was
lying there against the wall between the
lamp and the head of the bed that would
be on the left side the court were then
shown pictures of the corridor leading
to the bathroom as well as the bathroom
itself where the story has fired his gun
on that Valentine's Day morning their
wardrobes there that would be the
clothing wardrobes that leads into the
bathroom that would be their passage
between the clothing cobbles on both
sides and when we get to the wall you
turn right into the bathroom
that is the first captured or empty
cartridge that you would see them after
you have turned right there at the wall
that would be the entrance into the
bathroom first tile as you approach that
there is a blood sport and also on the
left side against the wall there are
also blood sports and the cartridge case
at the left where the circle is now that
is correct melody that rate birthday did
you see that today of the incident the
the bagging on the ball as well as the
splinters of wood on the floor that is
correct
those are the first pieces when you come
into the bathroom
as you approach on the right hand side
that would be the bath area and in front
you would see the baths and also the
towels that are there in between the
towels and the wall was also an empty
cartridge that where the wood is had
counted the third tile just again the
path there is an empty cartridge there
that is the photo of the path which was
on the left hand side and left hand
corner and inside the bath blood spots
and a piece of wood
if you
tend to the to your ID where it's shown
on photo 88 this is where you would come
up in 4 298 there are small slots for
that you would see and this on the sides
of that basil this is the cricket bit
which we found in front of the basin on
the floor with the towel and the blood
that was there and the bullet cartridge
between the tower and the cricket bed
just for orientation those are the same
towels that one can see imparted of 88
the firearm that you can see there is
that the position that you saw that far
on for the first time that is the
position that is the position position
by lady on photo as it is there it is
still cocked and the hammer is back Pam
Elizabeth but can we see on the left
hand side of photograph just above the
blood these are two cell phones
but you're saying that farm as it it's
lying that it's ready to fire its rate
if I just have to pull the trigger
Oh to the to the toilet
was open at the bathroom there were no
bad luck proving nothing on it that is
the surface of the tiles the entry into
the bathroom to the toilet on the
left-hand side next to the bath that
would be the panel that felt that form
from the door on we thought of the door
with that gear fee on the bottom side
not an insight of the tourism that's now
the entrance to the toilet the magazine
rack and everything as one can see it
there is our youth fantasy it was
erected and that is correct my lady
so a day of particularly graphic
evidence which at times left the stories
and reeva Steenkamp friends in
fierce distress we're joining me now to
discuss the day's courtroom testimony
it's teen spirits who's a former
forensic specialist with the South
African Police Service and I taught long
who's an attorney and you have on
occasion acted as a judge thank you for
joining us right not long what's your
judgement about how the two lawyers are
doing at the moment who's coming out on
top still very early days obviously and
we're just hearing the state's witnesses
being called but what's your view about
how it's going I'm also just watching
with keen interest but let me tell you
what I think it's a whole maze but I
think there's a common thread that
shines through the whole maze most of it
that I suspect final will be thrown by
the wayside a few things are common
cause there's no doubt that Oscar says
we fight the four shots in my view and
my understanding of even the plea by the
defense there's no question about the
fact that Oscar intended to kill the
question is did he intend to kill the
intruder or did he intend to kill River
so there's no question about the
intention and and and in our law there's
a clear distinction between the
intention to kill which ordinarily would
amount to Mara and then the motive is
something else it's like if I shoot you
in self-defense there's no question
about me intending to shoot and kill you
but the motive being self-defense and
the pro level self-defense is there then
we saw this objective test the court
will have to look at your conduct or
circumstances taken into account and see
whether you acted like a reasonable
person because the court the law expects
it of you whether subjectively you you
get scared too quickly and is it to rush
your gun is not the test the test is
whether what is it in our law is what
kind of conduct is expected of someone
who feels safe under attack
and is armed like Oscar was the question
that would be the question that one I
will have to be determined because even
if it turned out to have been an
intruder and he intended to shoot and
kill the intruder if the Court finds
that on all circumstances or facts
evidence presented there was no
reasonable basis to suspect that he was
in danger like you could I'm sure we
must all now except we couldn't see
beyond that the door that had been
closed will not show whether he had and
sounds and if so we know that River is
not armed amongst others and we know
there was no intruder now the question
is on what basis did you defy those four
shots and if you look at where they were
fired there's no question about the
intention to kill so I'm saying even if
it turned out to have been an intruder
in Allah if I find it in truth in my
house I can hardly execute him okay but
say say you defending him you're the man
who's got to defend them you know how
are you gonna do that if I was to defend
him
I suspect out have chosen a different
cause what would that mean I would have
been more inclined to plead guilty
tell the truth about what happened and
if there was an argument and things like
those hopefully say an I suspect maybe
that will have happened it's one of the
many options something should have
triggered whatever happened where they
believe our study done or you don't and
then fight the full battle I think I
would have fought default a food battle
went on sentence rather than on the
merits he may be very grateful you're
not his lawyer in that case because he's
denying everything and he said there was
no argument they were in a loving
relationship and he's obviously pressing
her to prove his innocence
tenth Brits tell me as an investigator
what were the key things say you had to
name two key things from the pictures
that you saw today what they're talking
key things that you would seize on at
this stage well obviously the doors is
very prominent in this in in disguise
and I think the the blood spatter that
was also shown today I know there's
there was pictures shown off splattered
at or tops of black on furniture that
seems to be not in the same position or
not the same scene but out of way of the
normal way I said she was carried from
down the stairs I would
document us and we get the blood tasted
the fana is a diva's blood somebody
else's blood you want hearing a lot more
about that but thank you very much both
of you for your views I'm sure we'll be
hearing more about it tomorrow when
Barry Roux gets into the chair and takes
on the police investigator that's it for
today though remember we'll bring you
continuing coverage of the trial on Sky
News from 7:30 in the morning as well as
on Twitter Sky News for iPad and Sky
News for smartphone where you can see
the full and continuous live transcripts
of the court proceedings and of course
our special around that program at 9:30
every night